українці ведуть екзистенційну війну
проти російської агресії відчайдушного
та все ще рішучу боротьбу за право
вирішувати власне майбутнє
Та поки вони це роблять частина цього
майбутнього вже в Росії
Вони намагаються змінити ідентичність
їхню культуру це дуже легко зробити коли
ти спочатку їх обстрілюєш вбиваєш їхніх
батьків ґвалтуєш їхніх матерів а потім
кажеш що ми Дбаємо про вас
нації ганофонд їх діти - це
А це майбутнє і тому вони діють чітко
спланованими
чистка спланованими задумами
це саме по собі є порушенням женевських
конвенцій і міжнародного права тому що
Женевський конвенції дуже чітко
стверджують що діти повинні мати
можливість поїхати додому
обвивачують у депортації українських
дітей з окупованих територій за
підступною та продуманою схемою
[музика]
міжнародний кримінальний суд звинуватив
президента Росії Володимира Путіна у
воєнних злочинах але не через масові
вбивства в Бучі не через масові
поховання в Ізюмі чи бомбардування
театру повного дітей у Маріуполі
йдеться про нібито систематичну
депортацію українських дітей до Криму та
Росії
ми уважніше Розглянемо як і чому росіяни
це роблять та як українські жінки
повертають дітей назад
[музика]
діти захищені женевськими конвенціями
1949 року Є спеціальні вказівки щодо
поводження з ними якщо вони розлучаються
зі своїми батьками під час війни стаття
4 говорить про те що дітей необхідно
евакуювати в безпечні зони коли це
можливо і возз'єднати з їхніми родинами
росіяни не приховують той факт що вони
вивозили дітей з України ці фотографії
як і інші які ми покажемо вам у цьому
звіті надійшли з російських державних
ЗМІ там Влада каже що дітей евакуювали
задля їхньої власної безпеки але їм
нібито не вдалося встановити зв'язок з
родинами Та здається відправляти дітей
назад ніхто не планує
женевські конвенції дуже чітко
стверджують що діти повинні мати
можливість повернутися додому їх слід
передати у третю країну Вони повинні
мати можливість Зателефонувати своїм
батькам І бути зареєстрованими в
червоному хресті та Організації
Об'єднаних Націй
ніаль Реймонд з лабораторія гуманітарних
досліджень єльського університету
Івані з відкритих джерел виявило те що
вони називають широкомасштабною
депортацією та перевихованням
українських дітей федеральним урядом
Росії
ось звідки їх везуть частину України
окупованих росіянами наприклад з
Херсонської області і ось куди їх везуть
звіт ідентифікував мережу щонайменше
40-трьома місцями по всьому Криму та
Росії
здебільшого це табори в місцях навколо
Чорного моря і аж до Єкатеринбурга в
Центральній Росії та навіть недалекому
сході
дослідники мають записи про щонайменше 6
тисяч дітей які були доставлені в ці
місця але уповноважена з прав дитини
України вважає що цифра може бути значно
більшою ми передбачаємо що Росія викрала
близько 200 тисяч
українських дітей хоча на сьогодні за
даними національного інформаційного
порталу діти війни ви можете побачити
цифру в 16 000
226 дітей за якими У нас є точні
персональні дані і заяви від батьків
родичів інших знайомих свідків або
місцевої локальної влади А про факт
депортації чи примусово переміщення
дитини
ніхто не знає з кількох Дітей забрали
прослідкувати що відбувається на все що
окупованій території неможливо а деякі
сім'ї мають свої складні причини не
звертатися до влади але якою б не була
оцінка за кожною цифрою стоїть дитина і
в більшості випадків сім'я намагається
її повернути
ми зустріли одну з таких жінок в Херсоні
у січні коли її донька була зниклою
безвісти
[музика]
Це Вікторія її рідне місто Херсон було
окуповане російськими військами протягом
8 місяців за цей час її доньку Катю
вивезли до Криму
[музика]
синяки перші синці перші подряпини на
цьому майданчику все тут було
Ну вона маленька ще зовсім їй був рік
коли ми будували тут все ще маленькі
зовсім були дітки
А ось велика гойдалка вона на ній була
готова кататися постійно усі дітки у
пісочниці граються а вона на гойдалці
Каті було 12 коли почалося
повномасштабне вторгнення Росії на
територію України чуйна і творча
дівчинка вона малювала писала вірші та
казки і все ж вона знала що відбувається
каже нам її мати
Просто я хотіла щоб вона поїхала просто
відпочила від цього всього від цієї
постійної напруженої ситуації від цих
військових машин ось цих
машин
ввечері лягаєш спати і страшно було якщо
приїжджає російська військова техніка це
не так страшно було а коли вони їдуть з
автоматами і прицілом на вікна наводять
світять ось це звичайно було страшно Я
думала що може дитина там відпочине
просто від усього
может ребенок Там отдохнёт просто от
всего
вона хотіла щоб Катя була якомога далі
від вибухів які тривають на відстані
хоча росіян уже давно немає і табір про
який вона говорила це табір відпочинку
куди вона відправила Катю думаючи що там
буде безпечно вона прийняла запрошення
від вчителів на яких окупаційна влада
тиснула з вимогою переселити дітей
Поехали на
поїхала на вокзал у річпорт там пером
стояв і дуже багато дітей їхало
виходить там чотири пороми відправлялися
з дітками
я не думала що так багато дітей їде у
табір
там від маленьких до Великих їхали
були дітки яким і 7 і 8 років були і
15-16
обійнялись вона каже Ну все мам скоро
побачимось
і ось це скоро до сьогодні триває
[музика]
росіяни забрали дітей не лише всіма які
відправили їх якомога далі від бойових
дій Вони часто націлювалися на
найуразливіші верстви населення
забираючи дітей безпосередньо у матерів
одиначок які мають фінансові труднощі і
вони йшли у місця де жили групи дітей
без батьків тут була група середній
хлопчиків
від 9 до 11 років тут і ми це все
прибрали щоб не пилилось
Сагайдак він директор дитячого будинку
який був тут раніше діти
залили того що він називає
соціально-психологічною реабілітацією
коли почалося повномасштабне вторгнення
він знав що вони під загрозою
в Україні війна вже йде 8 років а от і
за ці вісім років Ми вже бачили все і
бачили як з Луганської і Донецької
області вивозять дітей і
ну я знав що така участь якщо я нічого
не зроблю така участь бути очікувати і
нас що має опинимось
[музика]
разом з дітьми десь на російській
території
Він вирішив переїхати до дітей щоб краще
їх захистити спершого дня навели
конспіративне життя
ми не гуляли не виходили на вулицю на
стадіон
ми по 15 хвилин Кожна група виходила
сюди в двір Сагайдак знав що мовчазність
не працюватиме так довго і Що в якийсь
момент росіяни з'являться до дітей тому
він перевіз їх у приватні будинки деякі
поїхали до далеких родичів інших взяли
до себе співробітники
це ледь не закінчилося катастрофою коли
водій який вивозив дітей випадково не
натрапив на російський КПП що приїхав з
центру
завдяки кмітливій дівчинці яка почула
їхню історію вони втекли А вчителька
прикинулася тіткою дітей один залишився
з вихователькою другий підійшов до дітей
но спасло то що старша дівчинка 16 років
вона була при інструктажі коли я
проводив вона прибула присутня і вона
повторила все слово в слово Ну і
звичайно їх відпустили Ну а водію
сказали Якщо ще раз
Збереш ми тебе розстріляємо
така була ситуація звичайно всі тут не
посивіли
[музика]
такі діти як ті яких пан Сагайдак
намагався захистити утворили одну групу
яку ідентифікували у своїй доповіді
єльські дослідники росіяни стверджують
що забирають дітей з українських
закладів задля їхньої безпеки чи для
утримання медичної допомоги але
потрапивши на контрольовану Росією
територію дітям видають російське
громадянство Та вони поглинаються
російською системою відстежити їх може
бути неможливо росіяни не дають жодних
можливе жодного разу ніяких гуманітарних
коридорів для визволення дітей саме з
цих закладів на безпечну територію і з
часом просто самостійно їх украдали
іншу групу складають такі діти як Катя
діти з сім'ями батьки думають що
відправляють дітей на безплатний
відпочинок у крим чи Росії але діти
проходять перевиховання А в деяких
випадках і військовий вишкіл і головне
вони не повертаються додому Чому вони
відправляють своїх дітей як і Катя
багато хто довіряє вчителям які роблять
таку пропозицію
Вони мають глибокі та тривалі стосунки з
цими вчителями друге аспект полягає в
тому що вони підписали і ми бачили ці
документи бланки довіреностей надання
згоди уряду РФ до Росія не підписує
формуляр про контрольний орган і тому
вони використовують довіреність у
відкритий спосіб що робить недійсними
міжнародні визначення згоди тож по суті
це була пастка
Вікторія з Херсона каже що потрапила в
таку пастку лише через деякий час Вона
зрозуміла що наробила
Мені здається що якби вони хотіли
привести дітей назад Вони привезли б їх
ще тоді коли обіцяли
Катя мені каже що у них там є головний
прізвище у нього Астахов по-моєму
і вона каже що він там головний стежить
за ними
сказав що він їм сказав що ви додому не
повернетеся ви повернетеся додому тоді
коли Херсон стане російським
[музика]
Мені здається це була моя найжахливіша
угода у всьому житті якби можна було
повернути все назад я б ніколи її туди
не відпустила
діти з центру Сагайдака не потрапили до
рук росіян але це могло статися
Він показує нам запис камер
відеоспостереження на якому вони
побачили як чоловіки зі зброєю
вриваються в дитячий будинок
росіяни нас знайшли в червні місяці
до цього часу я вже сховав всіх дітей
мене залишилось в центрі Тільки 5
дорослих хлопців і Коли вони прийшли
вони шукали дітей де діти
це ми центр реабілітації Діти прийшли
реабілітацію і пішли звідки вони прийшли
те що він зробив було неймовірно
небезпечним але вважає що задля того щоб
запобігти викраденню дітей і викладені
коли їхні ідентичності варто було
ризикувати за наше дерево щастя
це найменше наш хлопчик Міша
і це всі 52 дитини Які в нас були в
центрі нам подарували це дерево і ми
провели конкурс на цьому родинному
дереві будуть не тільки фотографії дітей
але будуть фотографії працівників будуть
фотографії волонтерів благодійників які
нам допомагали вижити в цій ситуації
[музика]
То хто відповідальний за все це
не поодинокі випадки
тисячі можливо десятки тисяч українських
дітей були вивезені в десятки таборів у
Криму та по всій Росії
для цього потрібні люди Планування
організація та гроші
а в Росії це має прийти якимсь чином
зверху
киця на жінку з якою розмовляє Путін
вона є уповноваженою президента РФ справ
дітей Марія Львова Білова
як і її боса міжнародний кримінальний
суд звинуватив її у викраденні
українських дітей і вона навіть бере в
цьому особисту участь
[музика]
Кремля це робить її не військовим
злочинцем а гуманітарним лідером
вони пов'язані з цими викраданнями
трьома основними способами
один із них у травні Минулого року Путін
видав указ про надання українським дітям
громадянство в Росії
по-друге уряд Росії змінив закон щоб
дозволити усиновлення українських дітей
і надати премію приблизно 200 доларів на
місяць для російських сімей які
усиновлять українських дітей
по-третє Це загальнодержавний підхід
чотири регіональні губернатори відіграли
важливу роль у сприянні та фінансуванні
переміщення українських дітей до Росії
та їхньої депортації
Таким чином ми встановили що російське
керівництво включно з самим президентом
Росії безпосередньо віддало накази про
викрадання дітей Ми знаємо що вони
полегшили російським парам усиновлення
цих дітей і вони отримали російське
громадянство русифікація це термін який
ми часто чули в цьому контексті змушення
дітей відмовлятися від своєї
ідентичності і по суті ставати росіянами
це те що обурює українців які
сприймаються як напад на душу їхньої
країни
для кожної нації а-а генофонд їх діти -
це це скарб це майбутнє і тому вони
діють чітко спланованими задумами Да
вбиваючи дітей наносячи їм поранення
задаючи їм сексуальне насилля а задаючи
їм психологічних травм викрадаючи їх
змінюючи їм громадянство передаючи їх на
усиновлення під опіку громадянам
Російської Федерації і все це є не чим
іншим як актом геноциду українського
народу через українських дітей саме це і
є їх мета і вони роблять все для того
щоб її виконати або
цих дітей яких вони викрали
перенавчити переламати як вони самі Про
це говорять в багатьох своїх виступах
і знову це триває вже не один рік
вони мали цей план ще до того як вони
зайшли на українську землю вони
розпочали свою реалізацію страшного
задуму ще від початку анексії Криму
14-му році коли створили так званий
потяг Надії який віз громадян російської
федерації для незаконного усиновлення до
Криму я незаконного усиновлення
українських дітей але є ще й інші більш
практичні причини це не просто напад на
Україну для російського керівництва така
політика важлива щоб посилати меседжі
росіянам
це дуже потужний спосіб сказати що ми
рятуємо цих дітей від нібито нацистів
це справді суть програми і ви бачите що
вони пишаються цим і публічно
повідомляють про це тому що це є метою
це дійсно вистава для
внутрішньополітичного глядача і люди
повинні розуміти що це не секретна
операція це піар хід на базовому рівні
для українців це систематичне викрадення
дітей для росіян це гуманітарна операція
але для спостерігачів це ситуація із
заручниками
найстрашніша річ у певному сенсі вже
сталося а саме вони забрали дітей і чому
це так катастрофічно Ну тепер у Росії є
важелі впливу в них є важелі впливу яких
у них не було раніше щодо будь-яких
переговорів щодо полонених чи
переговорів про припинення бойових дій
вони забрали дітей це фундаментальний
важіль незалежно від того було це
задумано чи ні росіянам тепер доступна
стратегія кредитного плеча і вони це
знають
[музика]
то що можна зробити щоб повернути дітей
які зникли в російській системі у
більшості випадків Надії мало немає
системи та офіційної співпраці між
українською та російською сторонами
знайти дітей - це перший великий виклик
більшість з них не мають можливості
спілкуватися зі своїми сім'ями і Влада
часто переміщує їх і навіть якщо як у
Вікторії батьки знають де їхні діти вони
повинні поїхати і забрати їх зазвичай
цей варіант можливий лише для матерів
тому що чоловіки призовного віку не
можуть виїхати з країни
Вікторія мала їхати з Херсона до Криму
Зазвичай це займає 4 можливо 5 годин
їзди але їхати напряму вже небезпечно
їй довелося проїхати через Україну у
сусідню Польщу перетнути територію
Білорусі а потім проїхати через ворожу
територію загалом Це близько трьох тисяч
кілометрів в один бік
[музика]
повернення додому
на цьому автобусі приїхала Вікторія з
дочкою Катею вони обидві із групи яка
здійснила подорож разом Катя не знала що
за нею приїде мама
я була дуже рада
не вистачає слів щоб це описати
Вікторія та інші мами змогли це зробити
лише завдяки допомозі благодійної
організації сейв Ukraine вони допомогли
з логістикою паспортами автобусами та
навігацією на кордонах
за дітьми Таке відчуття ніби ми упекло
якесь потрапили Їхнє ставлення нас на
кордоні Чесно кажучи ледь не догола
роздягали щоб обшукати вони всі думали
що ми веземо якусь таємну інформацію
туди телефони перевіряли всі документи
повністю речі повністю всі діставали
Вікторія та Катя розповідають що вивести
дітей із таборів не було проблемою коли
там були мами Але перед цим вчителі
розповіли Каті зовсім іншу історію
нам точно не говорили жартами тільки ми
питали Коли додому він каже влітку
покупаєтесь в морі і додому все
але точну інформацію не говорив
Максимум що він знав що у березні він
постійно казав що після березня Після
весни влітку у серпні додому
тутешні Діти розповідають що табори були
не такими вже й поганими кажуть що до
них не ставилися погано але їх не
пускали додому і навіть не дозволяли
поговорити з батьками
ці дівчата думають що знають чому
вони не говорили бо ми не питали І тим
паче це заборонено це заборонено у
таборі говорити дітям бо може початися
істерика чоловік який допоміг їм виїхати
має іншу теорію це російська стратегія
для дітей
це русифікація українських дітей
Тому їм не потрібно їх бити і мучити це
дитина дитячий мозок дуже гнучкий
якщо ви щодня годуєте мозок своєю
пропагандистською отрутою то протягом
одного-двох місяців Ця дитина скаже Ой
може Росія і непогана це їхня стратегія
на сьогодні сейв Ukraine вдалося сприяти
поверненню 96 дітей але робити це їм
стає все важче на границі коли ми
виїжджали росіяни на кордоні між Росією
та білоруссю не випускали нас території
білорусів взагалі ні на одному кордоні
ні на другому кордоні нам довелося їхати
на міжнародний кордон до Латвії щоб
приїхати вже до Латвії щоб нас пустили в
Європу нас не хотіли пропускати Вони
тільки дізналися що українці діти з
табору все
ми розуміємо що у них є вказівки не
пускати дітей додому
і саме під час цієї місії ми розпізнали
що Вони намагаються заблокувати будь-яке
повернення в Україну
хочу нас є все документи офіційні
представники матері але вони говорять
дурниці що це заборонено що заборонено
повернутися дитині з батьками
нібито якщо ви перетинаєте кордон з
Росією ви не можете повернутися назад
громадська організація та українська
влада наполегливо працюють щоб повернути
вкрадених дітей про яких вони знають але
є непроговорена проблема яка ускладнює
ситуацію деякі сім'ї занадто налякані що
повідомити про зникнення своїх дітей і
вони можуть бути втрачені назавжди
одна з критичних речей яка має відбутися
прямо зараз полягає в тому що в багатьох
випадках батьки найбільше стурбовані
реакцією в Україні на те що їх сприймуть
як колаборантів з точки зору того що
вони спочатку відправляли своїх дітей у
деяких випадках а також стурбовані тим
що їх можуть сприйняти як колаборантів у
плані виїзду в Росію щоб повернути своїх
дітей
і тому існує критична роль яку має
відігравати український уряд на рівні
президента та вищого керівництва уряду
України
[музика]
у січні Міністр закордонних справ
України Дмитро Кулеба заявив що масове
викрадання українських дітей було однією
з найбільш неосвітлених тем війни але з
того часу багато чого сталося
розслідування призвели не лише до того
що міжнародний кримінальний суд висунув
звинувачення Путіну та Львову біології
також під санкції потрапили інші
російські посадовці та представники
української окупаційної влади
звинувачення серйозні те що росіяни
називають евакуацією за словами ООН може
вважатися актом геноциду Росія практично
повністю ізольована від Заходу але
багато інших країн де проживає близько
двох третин населення світу є або
нейтральними або орієнтованими на Росію
розслідувач з єльського університету
надання ліймонд каже що викрадення явно
суперечать міжнародному праву і якщо
щось було потрібно щоб спонукати країни
які не визначилися засудити Росію це
повинно стати приводом
йдеться про те щоб чітко показати для
міжнародної спільноти для тих країн які
ще не засудили програму викрадення дітей
і ще не засудили російське вторгнення в
Україну
і я думаю що це потужно з точки зору
створення дипломатичного впливу на Росію
щоб змінити курс
і все ж Кремль не демонструє жодних
ознак зміни курсу розслідувачі єльського
університету стверджують що принаймні
два заклади в Росії навчають українських
підлітків військовому вишколу Путін і
Львова Бєлова кажуть що програма буде
розширена якщо вона буде успішною
занепокоєння полягає в тому що цих дітей
можуть відправити назад в Україну і
змусити воювати зі своїми
повномасштабна війна Росії проти України
триває вже понад країни союзники стають
дедалі активнішими
щоразу коли західні країни робили
черговий крок щоб допомогти Україні
проти Росії поставало питання як не
провокувати Путіна Як не дати йому
зробити щось ще гірше ніж те що він уже
почав для тисяч українських сімей
росіяни вже здійснили найстрашніший
кошмари
забрали дітей
[музика]